Reporter: Dropping a nuclear
bomb inside a hurricane.
Reporter: Drop a nuclear bomb on them.
Reporter: The president
suggested bombing a hurricane
on multiple occasions.
Briefers reportedly told
the president, quote,
"We'll look into that."
Narrator: Believe it or
not, President Donald Trump
isn't the first person to
suggest we nuke a hurricane.
Back in the '50s, a
meteorologist named Jack Reed
introduced the idea as a
way to prevent hurricanes
from reaching the coast.
Announcer: High- and low-pressure areas
are recorded hourly at each station.
Narrator: And people have been asking why
we don't nuke hurricanes ever since.
In fact, the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration
has been asked this question so much,
it has a web page dedicated
to answering just that.
Alex Wellerstein: So, if
you set off a nuclear weapon
in a hurricane, not only do
we still have a hurricane,
now you have a radioactive hurricane.
So, that's not a positive development.
Narrator: For perspective,
a hurricane can generate
the same amount of energy
throughout its lifetime
as 10,000 nuclear bombs.
And the physical size of a hurricane
is a major issue as well.
Hurricane Irma measured 420 miles across.
That's 70 times as large as the
blast zone for "Little Boy,"
the nuclear bomb dropped over Hiroshima.
So, detonating an atomic
bomb inside a hurricane
is sort of like poking
a rhino with a stick
and expecting it to just
get out of your way.
It's not gonna happen.
Oh, and then there's the issue of
highly radioactive nuclear fallout.
Wellerstein: Best-case scenario
is that it rains out very quickly.
And so the area that
you set the weapon off
becomes highly radioactive
and contaminated.
That's your best-case scenario.
A more worse-case scenario is
what if that somehow
stays in the hurricane
and moves as the hurricane,
say, makes landfall?
Narrator: In a worst-case
scenario, winds from the hurricane
would quickly distribute
the radiation throughout
the entire storm.
Basically turning it from a
massive storm with wind and rain
into a massive storm with
radioactive wind and rain
that's 10 times larger and
millions of times more powerful
than any nuclear bomb in history.
Not to mention, hurricanes move fast.
In 2012, Hurricane Sandy
traveled over 2,000 miles
from the Caribbean Sea
up the US East Coast
in just 10 days.
And we know from past experience
what nuclear fallout does to
an ocean and people nearby.
Wellerstein: It was in 1954,
the United States set off
a very large thermonuclear
weapon in the Marshall Islands,
and it contaminated a
lot of fish in the area.
Japan ended up having a
moratorium on fish consumption
for some time as a result of this.
And you could detect the
radioactivity in fish
for thousands of miles.
Narrator: Plus, scientists
estimated that 55%
of all cancers in those living
closest to the bomb site
might be attributed to the
bomb's nuclear fallout.
So, if we had nuked, say, Hurricane Sandy,
not only would there
have been the $65 billion
in damage repair,
but who knows how much
more it would have cost in
the additional damage to
fishing industries, healthcare,
and even the simplest things
you might not think about.
Wellerstein: Because you
can't just rebuild the house.
Now you've also got to remove, you know,
several inches of topsoil
and destroy the original material
and rebuild it from scratch
if you want people to be able
to live there without
increasing the cancer risk.
Narrator: Suffice it to
say, nuking a hurricane,
as NOAA puts it, is "not a good idea."
Wellerstein: It's less of
a sort of doomsday scenario
as it is just a, like, really bad idea.
No-benefit scenario.